six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try our caller from
the seven one nine area code caller from
seven one nine who's this where you're
calling from hi David this is Jacob
calling from Trinidad Colorado
go ahead Jacob I have two questions
related to money in politics first do
you think that citizens united was
wrongly decided and if you do you think
that a constitutional amendment should
be passed to overturning it assuming it
was possible okay so I do believe
citizens united was the wrong decision I
think it's a destructive and horrible
decision before the appointment and
confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh I
probably would have been of the mindset
I was of the mindset that there are
cleaner paths towards the effective
removal of citizens united than a
constitutional amendment because that's
such an uphill battle with the
confirmation of Supreme Court justice
Brett Kavanaugh and the continued
radicalization of the Supreme Court I'm
actually now almost swinging back to and
I think genk from the young turks may
have said something along these lines
I'm almost back to maybe the
constitutional amendment is actually the
most likely path forward I don't think
it's likely but it might be more likely
than getting Supreme Court rulings that
will effectively overturn citizens
united so I think we're in trouble I
think neither path is particularly
likely now but I would support a
constitutional amendment okay I guess
just to follow up if I can yeah do you
think that the goal should be to make
money from corporations and the rich
meaningless as a political tool rather
than banning it altogether because I do
think that maybe there is a potential
free speech element to contributing to
political campaigns well you you're very
quickly if you want to go to free speech
throughout the question is is money
speech if it is speech then should
everybody should there be unequal
amounts of speech when it comes to
influencing elections because if you
believe in one person one vote all of a
sudden if money is speech and there's no
limits not everybody has the same amount
of influence and I think that that
presents a different sort of legal
argument but I think that the the
sort of more interesting angle here that
you bring up is are there ways to make
the money irrelevant I don't actually
know if there are I think that the the
most direct path is you say we have a
set amount of financing for elections
it's public financing there's a set
amount there's a set period we don't
start earlier and earlier every election
cycle and you sort of make everything
uniform because uniformity in that way
we don't always want we know I don't
know too many people arguing for
equality of outcome but if you set up
elections with equal opportunity meaning
everybody gets the same amount of money
the same amount of time that in and of
itself would be a huge improvement I
don't know how you make the money
meaningless I don't know how you do that
all right well thank you for taking my
call
thank you for calling it appreciate it
campaign finance very a very important
issue